vous avez qui fait partir à l'aventuré
on a changé
la venturi l'expérience allait peut-être
subtop après c'est c'est ce qu'on montre
de nous qui est c'est quoi alors qu'est
ce qui vous dérange
moi personnellement rien ouais avoir moi
c'est les montages c'est quoi pourquoi
on fait passer un peu on donne un peu
une image de ce qui n'est pas le reflet
de moi tout simplement donc c'est quoi
l'image qu'on dise et donnez-vous à
l'arrière par exemple j'ai vu bac ont
donné l'image de moi de quelqu'un de
macho de quelqu'un de d'irrespectueux
alors que ça c'est pas du tout passé
comme ça et c'est pour ça qu'avant hier
quand il ya eu la crise de jalousie
jalousie en fait ouais c'est vrai c'est
maria il ya juste marianne qui s'exprime
à la fin suite à une dispute
ouais et la production en fait fait un
montage et qui est qu il s insinuer
comme quand j'avais moi on va vraiment
d'ardres espère alors que parce que
marianne a laissé une photo de son ex
accroché sur le prix gonflés oui ça
c'est vous a confié qu'elle s'entendait
toujours très bien avec cellex c ça nous
on a une photo nous de balata vous
aimerez vous serrez le cueillir une
photo d'un sexe sur le frigo
alors je vous dire j'en ai un bon bah
oui mais là où les brunes d'offrir le
frigo de façon d'une enfant je n'oublie
jamais vous exprimer je suis en fait
c'est de garder contact avec ds quand on
fait ce genre d'expérience moi j'arrive
je rencontre marianne je pense qu'elle
n'est pas passée à autre chose et moi
par contre j'ai fait j'ai fait le ménage
avant de faire cette expérience donc je
me suis dit moi je les fais elle le fait
pas alors je vais vous dire ce qui m'a
plu là dedans c'est que je sens une
sincérité
bah oui rien bah c'est ça qui est
important est le mec comme moi il n'a
pas de suggestions juste pour faire le
beau à la télé et se dira prêt va encore
faire le bois la télé c'est encore la
production qui me donne cette image
après
merci c'est gentil s'est regardé pour la
première fois franchement je déteste
coach et j'avais dît si vous avez des
vrais sentiments mais bien sûr ces sacs
à bord moi j'aime les mecs comme toi tu
vois voilà qui font l'émission en
relation tous comprend alors non à cette
émission quand on a la fièvre on l'a
fait parce qu'il ya des mais c'est super
positif pour vous il vous plait ya
quelqu'un qui parle
non quand même merci non quand on fait
cette expérience on a fait avec la plus
grande sincérité moi je veux pour ma
part je suis papa de deux enfants je
vais pas m'aventurer à faire une
expérience comme celle ci sous prétexte
de juste de me montrer à la télé ou quoi
que ce soit c'est ça parce qu'il ya des
gens aussi qu'ils le font parfois on a
l'impression pour les mauvaises raisons
et vous c'est ça qui aimait ses grands
vraiment chercher vraiment l'amour vrai
qu'ils ont vraiment sincèrement vraiment
je la fais vraiment pour rencontrer la
femme de ma vie
alors pourquoi les scènes de tension
entre aurélien et et marianne on peut
comprendre
je peux comprendre aurélien mine de rien
c'est vrai que ya la photo
oui de l'ex beau fatou est la photonique
sur le frigo
ah non jamais je lui interdis raquel à
la fouille d'une photo d'où des jambes
et ça c'est pas possible c'est vrai mais
je voulais vous dire c'est elle que vous
êtes là vous êtes sincère mais dans
l'émission c'est problématique parce que
l'image c'est l'image que vous reflétez
moi par exemple je trouvais que vous
étiez macho l'histoire des valises vous
la laisser sortir les vallées on a une
mauvaise image devant regardant
l'émission bien c'est vrai après l'image
qu'on y voyait même lieu dès lors quoi
voir comment ça se fait qu'on voit ça
tous que vous ayez simplement fait là
par exemple
bah je vais faire bref par rapport à ce
qui s'est passé hier il ya marianne qui
s'expriment chip leur qui dit que je
vais manquer de respect jamais de
manquer de respect je n'ai pas insulté
il n'y a pas eu de violence comment on
pourrait croire maintenant aujourd'hui
avec ce qu'elle a fait hier
le seul truc qui s'est passé c'est qu'on
a une dispute et en plus sa part d'un
geste déplacé qu'elle a qu'elle a eue
envers moi et suite à ce geste
écologique
c'est un geste déplacé je vais pas
rentrer dans des polémiques c'est une
interview ce sans le faire exprès voilà
un gars très sympa sans faire exprès
mais bon c'était un peu une gaminerie
envie de dire et je suis passé je suis
passé sur ça mais là je me suis rendu
compte à ce moment là que c'était pas
une personne qui était compatible sur
des trucs comme ça avec moi et donc à la
suite c'est que j'ai remis en cause donc
nos compatibilité
le travail des experts l'expérience et
je me suis dit non en fait c'est la
bonne personne tout simplement